bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france d'abord au quel
bilan vous faites vous de cette visite
du président français emmanuel macron au
moyen orient et dernièrement donc il a
clôturé sa cette visite en arabie
saoudite pour le président français cela
semble être une mission accomplie
puisque il a obtenu une initiative
commune avec ryad pour votre pays le
liban
oui bonsoir la france a effectivement
joué un rôle très important dans le
rétablissement des relations entre
économique entre l'arabie saoudite et le
liban
il y avait une crise qui est donc été
terrible pour le liban qui en fait
exporte à peu près pour 500 millions de
dollars vers l'arabie saoudite en
agriculture en produits industriels et
c'est essentiel pour le liban de sortir
de cet embargo que l'arabie saoudite lui
avait imposé un embargo donc contre
l'autorisent l'embargo contre les
importations les exportations est
également en fait tout ce qui était il y
avait un risque au niveau des 550 milles
libanais qui travaillons dans lé golfe
dont à peu près 350 milles dans leurs
habits on va peut-être rappeler les
origines de cette crise diplomatique
entre ryad et des routes c'est
l'engagement saoudien dans la guerre au
yémen
oui tout à fait en fait c'est un
ministre
libanais au sein du gouvernement mikati
qui unissent procès riant proches du
président
qui avait tenu des propos contre
l'intervention de l'arabie saoudite au
yémen et mais cela avant même d'être
nommé il était en fête à quai pour ses
propos et je pense en fait est juste un
excellent outil pour imposer des sens
puisque le véritable en fait la
véritable cible pour l'arabie saoudite
c'était en fait le hezbollah dans ce
qu'il considère que le liban et son
contrôle du hezbollah
ont cessé la vision de l'arabie saoudite
et tonky l'arabie saoudite cherché à
punir le liban posta
en fait c'est tout cela montre qu'il ya
un véritable problème au liban c'est que
il y a en fait différents partis
politiques différents leaders politiques
qui se tourne vers détroit et il ya
également des plus chères qui essayent
de sea mist et liban c'est pour cela
qu'il est arrivé à la neutralité du
liban et neutralité qui doit être
positive comme c'est le cas par exemple
pour le sultanat de oman qui est impayée
neutre positif est également une autre
réalité qu'ils soient permanents et
reconnu internationalement comme c'est
le cas par exemple du turkménistan donc
il faut une même une conférence
internationale au niveau des nations
unies pour répondre en fait faire
déclarer le liban un pays neutre reconnu
internationalement
est-ce que après l'entretien entre le
premier ministre libanais emmanuel
macron et le prince héritier mohammed
bin salman
la réconciliation elle est véritablement
scellé avec votre pays
je pense pas que la réconciliation un
soir soit véritablement à sceller parce
qu'il ya différents problèmes qui
persistent l'arabie saoudite considèrent
le hezbollah comme un ennemi et
considère que le liban est entre les
mains du hezbollah donc ce problème va
persister et continuer mais encore une
fois ce qui est essentiel c'est que il
faut que la souveraineté du liban soit
respecté que l'indépendance du liban
soit respecté que les pays étrangers
cesse de s'immiscer dans les affaires
internes libanaises est également que
les libanais eux mêmes les politiciens
les partis politiques cesse de regarder
vers l'étranger cesse de demander l'aide
de thèmes telles puissances étrangères
il faut que le liban soit véritablement
souverain et que la neutralité soit
appliquée au liban est reconnu par tous
le liban ne pourra pas s'en sortir sans
que l'arabie saoudite l'iran les
etats-unis la france et ses
reconnaissent l'indépendance du liban
reconnaissent la poule d'indépendance de
la politique étrangère du liban
reconnaissent une neutralité pour ce
pays et qu'en même temps les libanais
arrêts demandez l'aide de l'arabie l'est
de la france les états unis l'aide de
l'iran l'aide de la russie et de la
chine etc il faut arrêter il faut
qu'aujourd'hui les libanais
reconstruisent de le système comme si
possible michel fayyad parce qu'on voit
bien là l'initiative franco
saoudiennes pour justement permettre à
nouveau le liban de de poursuivre donc
les importations qui étaient interdites
par ryad comment c'est possible comment
le liban peut s'en sortir sans une aide
extérieure on voit que la france est au
chevet du liban maintenant depuis
plusieurs années comment est ce que vous
vous voyez les choses à ce niveau
oui moi quand je dis qu'il faut pas
d'ingérence politique de l'étranger et
qui dans les deux sens comme jeudi du
point de vue des pays étrangers vers le
liban et des libanais vers l'étranger ça
veut pas dire que je suis complet
d'informations à le contraire je suis
pour il ne l'était financière du fmi de
la banque mondiale et de la communauté
internationale envers le liban mais pour
cela il faut également une véritable un
véritable changement au niveau politique
et au niveau financier au liban il faut
que le liban s'engagent dans des efforts
de restructuration bancaire et sans cela
il n'y aura rien il faut qu'il y ait un
véritable changement politique mais pas
seulement chez les ch et la communauté
chrétienne mais également chez la
communauté musulmane celui de la
communauté musulmane chiite et la
communauté druze et autres dons qu'il
est il est important qu'il y ait un
véritable changement à tous les niveaux
politique c'est pour ça qu'il faut des
élections et qu'il faut un tel état de
changements donc financier parce
qu'aujourd'hui le liban est une banque
au cra ci étant que cette banque au cra
si elle n'est pas en fait
changé on lui retire son pouvoir hors
change les choses on pourra pas arriver
à des réformes aujourd'hui vous parler
de la gym mikati najib mikati c'est
qu'est le communisme liban oui mais
c'est le deuxième homme le plus riche du
pays le premier temps son frère elle
s'est lui-même un banquier le ministre
des finances et est un ancien de la
banque centrale il était membre de la
banque sans faille juste avant sa
nomination comme ministre des finances
et aujourd'hui on n'entend qu'eux les
seules réformes qu'il compte qu'ils
veulent faire pour résoudre la crise
financière c'est vendre les actifs de
l'état au lieu de faire payer en fait
les banques qui sont les laits et la
banque centrale qui sont les véritables
de coupables entre guillemets de la
crise financière au liban en tout cas
elle il y avait urgence justement pour
permettre au liban de de se relancer
puisque l'économie libanaise elle est
exemple
oui les niveaux économique c'est terry
vous avez aujourd'hui le trois quarts
des libanais qui sont qui sont pauvres
et ça va continuer à se dégrader s'il
n'y a pas les téléphones qui sont
entreprises donc effectivement il faut
que l'europe que le gouvernement se
réunissent aujourd'hui on l'a réglé une
première étape qui consistait donc avec
la démission du ministre de
l'information mais il ya également un
autre problème qui reste comme un noeud
pour que ce gouvernement se réunissent
c'est que en fait c'est les partis
chiites mais également il ya des leaders
summit qui re qui en fait veulent le
départ du juge bitar qui est le juge
d'investigation denquête est chargé
justement de l'explosion afin de trouver
qui sont les responsables
de l'explosion au port de beyrouth donc
il ya également ce lieu qui empêche pour
le moment le conseil des ministres est
très très rapidement le regard que vous
portez sur les contrats passés
par la france avec notamment à abu dhabi
80 rafale vendus et notamment les
contrats avec l'arabie saoudite est ce
que c'est bon ça pour la stabilité du
moyen orient
vous savez c'est un succès commercial
pour la france après bien sûr on peut
avoir
les pensées sur le fait qu'effectivement
est ce que tout ça ça ça rentre pas dans
l'espèce de guerre froide qui se joue
aujourd'hui entre d'un côté les pays
sunnites comme l'arabie saoudite les
émirats arabes unis et les un péché qu
environ il ya cette guerre froide qui a
commencé depuis 2003 où on voit que sans
se confronter directement à lille c'est
à dire en l'arabie saoudite des émirats
arabes unis et se battre sur d'autres
terrains comme par exemple la syrie
l'irak ou même le liban ou le yemen et
donc il est important aussi donc baisser
d'arrivée certaines pacification de la
région en essayant de rapprocher les
iraniens les saoudiens et des émirati
les égyptiens etc
mais encore une fois il est il est très
important que le liban qui lui reste en
dehors des divisions des guerre froide
qu'elle qui sont entre ces pays là parce
que le liban est un pays fragile où il
ya des communautés sunnite et chiite
comme monter chrétienne est donc cet
équilibre fragile ne peut pas résister
s'il n'y a pas de neutralité donc cette
neutralité c'est vraiment la clé de la
solution pour le liban merci beaucoup à
vous michel fayyad analystes politiques
et financiers